welcome to this video playing Adele
mower with white from France I played it
before when I had a very good position
and blundered this let's see what we get
here modern benoni is going for a quick
h5 push let's see transporting to samish
type of position yeah maybe I should
have yeah I never know it's a yes yes I
should go back now ok I want to regroup
the night first to what is he doing them
that's that's really a good idea it
really really is getting the Queen down
ok
it's always in danger of being trapped
let's see if what if i go Bishop f4 here
just just attacking the pawn checking d6
ok but this is this is like resigning
almost giving giving this up I don't
let's see how do i do i punish this with
f45 on f4 f5 install this this weird
queen here ok this is this is a good
news and let's see you might have quindi
for this this could be could be a
problem
hmm still still a 5 with 94 coming
oh come on
good 24 the check this is this is silly
why what did i do that now Queenie fries
with a check I wanted to play 94 but he
checks on deform oh man
yeah very stupid 95 how can you play a
five year ah this this was he cannot
never don't know it's always frustrating
I mean this is what's really absolutely
not playable what he did but just don't
do we five he's just it's lost in this
position it's simply like that and now
I'm I have to to fish here for for some
stuff
Jim so he allows me to take on h5 let's
do that
check I don't understand anything here
check
so there's some
it's still not easy still not easy
it takes takes root g one takes on c3
takes on d3 takes on be to look be one
there is this night coming in that's not
easy so you can probably have to do it
rook c8 unbelievable unbelievable now
Roxy want i cannot Perry that that's
great just great
time warning
gather the only only a slight chance
left
maybe you can play Roxy one even maybe
habits but even still roop the age
should should be good
yeah just rip the aid will see one is
not working yeah what what what was so
difficult their group d 2 looks into
look see one
I could have resigned a long time ago
but somehow check check ok so if Chad
couldn't be too ok white resign yeah I
mean totally totally weird game
especially terrible is e 5 if I just go
King edge one year Black is in a
terrible situation and now he's screwing
and all the same I want to look at the
critical position I have no way to
switch this off unfortunately that both
people can can look at this I really
what do you want ok let's let him move
some stuff yeah whatever can how can I
can I stop this I want to analyze on my
own I don't really know how to do that
yeah whatever you want yeah yeah this is
this is just better for white the whole
way like us I just need to hear I just
need to avoid you five just this any
normal move mmm and black is sitting in
a terrible benoni it just like that yeah
I can I cannot analyze with him putting
putting stuff on the board he blundered
later but was some more lucky two
together win anyway it was a very weird
very weird game i wonder if i can switch
this off so it is totally annoying this
this moving yeah whatever okay thanks
for watching